we're going to talk about knowledge
graphs
knowledge graphs are a ai technology
that is used pretty much
anywhere online in any major platform or
system or application that we're using
on a daily basis
anytime you ask google or bing or your
favorite search engine a question it
will most likely use a knowledge graph
alongside many other types of techniques
to retrieve information and answer
questions so if for instance you are
asking um about bush house which is the
building where we are now any search
engine will provide a list of documents
maybe some ads of some form but
somewhere on that result page it will
give you some very specific information
about bush house it will provide
probably a picture of the entrance where
you came in and then it will say
well um this is an address
of this thing bush house that me as a
computer without any sort of
um human understanding
can nevertheless relate to so so that
string of characters bush house
all of a sudden has an address
and it has
perhaps
opening hours
and it has particular departments at
king's college that are located in this
building right
now if i go and
query national theater i will still get
information about
the address
because it's still a building
but perhaps it will not take tell me
anything about any
university departments because national
theatre is not a university or it's not
a location for a university right so how
does google know
all those things about the world around
us about london
well because
it uses
the knowledge ground and i say d because
actually google
is the company that has coined
this term but actually the principles
and the technologies have been around
for for
much much
longer in fact decades
and decades
where um ai researchers were building
so-called knowledge bases which are very
similar types of of i.t systems that are
encoding knowledge
information data i don't think we need
to go into a big discussion about what
these three mean and how how they are
different from each other they are in
this case in the example i had it's
about knowledge about london what
connects all these different pieces of
data together so this is the knowledge
graph this is the knowledge graph and
the knowledge graph
um
as it is today not just in the case of
google but pretty much any large
organization that that provides this
sort of
internet information services has one
they are
huge
databases
with
billions and billions of facts like this
bush house is located in london and at
this address right
um this information is extracted from
documents
um say
on the king's website somewhere there is
information about bush house and and
it's written probably in text
and google has the machinery to process
all this text and recognize that this
string bush house is probably a building
and and and learn that information that
structured information and
store that in their knowledge graph and
so then autograph ultimately
um you can you can imagine it as a um
as a database and that stores facts um
about things in the world and relations
between them
um and we in in
ai and in knowledge graph engineering we
distinguish between the actual data so
bush house national theatre and then
abstract data which is theaters
buildings universities so any university
most universities in the world will have
a set of common properties right they
will teach students
they will be located on a certain campus
they will have a certain number of
employees kings college london has
three or four actually different
campuses lse
also university shares many types of
properties also teaches students also
has employees but has different campuses
different address so there is the data
about lse in king's college london and
there's all these joint properties that
all types of things like lse like king's
college have
and that helps
in web search but in many other types of
ai applications as well so in question
answering
in recommendations of movies of products
and so on and so forth because
it basically allows that
recommender or search engine to provide
very specific very accurate to the point
answers rather than relying on
extracting those answers from natural
text and you see the difference actually
in search when sometimes you type
something and google says well people
also asked for this and this right and
then you have that question and you have
that little drop down list and a snippet
answer now some of those answers
sometimes
match what you're looking for but
sometimes they're
actually only remotely or not all
relevant and that's the difference a
computer has struggles
to
process and extract very specific types
of information from what we call
unstructured data which is text images
videos but it has no issue whatsoever or
much less
issue to um
work with data that is already
structured in a graph for instance my
simplistic view of graph being a thing
you plot on a piece of paper you know
two axes beyond paper you could have
many more axes is this what we're
looking at here so we're not talking
about charts okay right so we're not
talking about
um
visually displaying data
in a 2 3 or multi-dimensional visual
space we're talking about
a graph in a mathematical sense so a
graph consists of nodes and edges
we know graphs from computer networks
right so you have
um computers which are the nodes and
then the communication links between
them we know graphs from um geospatial
information systems maps right so you
have points on a map and then you have
roots you need all sorts of algorithms
to compute edges for instance in the
case of maps if you want to go from a to
b
you
can do that by passing multiple
intermediary nodes so when you say an
edge i mean we kind of had the example
of a map and that being a root in the
map yes what how do you define an edge
it's any type of relation right so for
bush house it could be has address so
let's just say that we represent the
nodes in these ovals and then we
represent the edges as
lines between
these nodes so we're talking about
bush house and we're talking about
king's college london right
and then so what's the relationship
between bush house and kcl campus off or
something yeah campus of or we could
call it building of kcl we can have
another
relationship that says bush house
has
picture
and here's my picture of bush house and
it could be an actual image all these
lines
can have different meanings so i can
have the has picture edge from bush
house from kcl you could have something
like
has logo and it points to another image
that is the logo um you could also have
some sort of has picture with some
picture of kcl who knows and there's an
image file here
so you can have different types of edges
this type of has picture edge and this
one here are the same so if you want to
have all pictures of things you can
query just like you would query with sql
in a database
you can have
any type of edge you want you label it
so you give it a name mine have arrows
that's mostly just for my understanding
because i want to say that the
image is something that belongs to which
house and not the other way around
sometimes you have edges that could have
arrows on both ends
so if you think about
elena has sibling
alex my brother
so the edge has sibling is what we call
symmetrical so if i'm his sister then
he's my brother say the moment when i
define the edge has sibling
from
the node elena
to the node alex
the computer where i can actually tell
the computer by the way there is also
the opposite edge if
i have
an edge or relationship
like is located in
so bush house is located in london you
see how
the graph actually starts to take shape
in london
and elena works
at busch house
and london
is located
in
england you can tell the computer well
is located in is a type of edge that is
what we call in mass transitive so if i
know that bush house is located in
london i know london is located in
england then i know that bushow is
located in england so you don't actually
have to look for
that sort of question if someone ever
would ask is bush house located in
england you don't actually need to look
for the data specifically you can what
you call infer it
so you can
from all this information that i have
written down
you can now infer additional knowledge
this is a bit like an ontology though
yes it is an ontology well it is based
on an ontology to be more specific the
ontology will be something about cities
and about buildings in cities and
buildings belonging to institutions and
people working in certain buildings is
there an easy a sort of free way people
could play with this or try this is
there something out there people could
download for developers the google
knowledge graph api is something that
then people can look at there's also
various open source
knowledge graphs available say wikipedia
has one it's called wikidata and it's
what they use to
manage all the
structured information they have so you
know when you go on a wikipedia article
and on the right hand side you see what
they call an info box bush house go on
wikipedia and then you'll see that comes
from a knowledge graph that is publicly
available and people can download it
it's quite big um but at the same time
you have lots of information that you
can play with and i don't know train a
neural network on and do all sorts of
wonderful things so yeah it's available
and and and there are smaller versions
as well for for people to to play with
it's super hard to know i mean there are
different things going on here there's
intelligence
which i think you've got to say maybe
some computer systems are intelligent at
least at certain things there's
sentience and there's consciousness and
they're slightly different than
intelligent things
so that big pointy spike in that
sunglasses sunglasses and if we